our workplaces are killing us in several
ways number one they're working us to
death too many hours hours have been
shown to be related for instance the
blood pressure in an almost monotonic
relationship workplaces are killing us
because they stress us an absence of job
control work-family conflict economic
and security is obviously stressful so
the combination of working us to death
and stressing us to death is what's
killing us we understand that people's
minds affect their bodies and stress is
of course a mental state and a mental
attitude so in some sense it's not that
surprising that things that make you
stressed nervous anxious feel out of
control would have enormous
physiological impact and that's what the
epidemiological literature has shown
really for a long time
so our contribution and the research
that we did was to take a bunch of stuff
that was kind of sitting there and put
it together so there were studies of
health effects of various workplace
stressors and there were estimates of
the prevalence of various workplace
stressors what we did is put this all
together in a big model to estimate the
total effects on population health and
healthcare costs
what we found when we put all these data
together is that our best estimate is
that there are about 120,000 excess
deaths annually just in the United
States and close to 200 billion dollars
in excess healthcare costs as a
consequence of what we call exposures to
harmful workplace conditions and those
would be things such as economic and
security absence of health insurance
shiftwork work-family conflict things
that either affect directly access to
health care like health insurance or put
stress and strain on people so when you
say what is the worst it depends upon
the outcome it turns out death is cheap
once you die your healthcare costs stop
so the biggest contributors to
healthcare costs are what I would call
chronic stressors things like work
family conflict and economic insecurity
the single biggest factor affecting
mortality is the absence of access to
health care which comes from not having
health insurance so the causes of costs
are a little bit different than the
causes of mortality because mortality
and costs are not perfectly correlated
things like economic insecurity and work
family conflict had pretty large effects
not as big as the absence of health
insurance or work hours but almost as
big so psychology matters as well
well I think for people employees they
need to understand that going to places
where they experience work family
conflicts shiftwork long work hours
economic and security don't get access
to health insurance that this is more
than just you know something that's
inconvenient this is something that
actually affects their well-being in a
deep and profound way and they ought to
take these factors into account as they
select their jobs for employers who are
concerned about health care costs they
should worry a lot about the work
environment at the moment employers
worry mostly about individual decisions
eating exercise smoking drinking things
like that are they worried about broad
social policy issues like how we pay for
health care in the United States a lot
of their excess healthcare costs come
from what happens to people every day in
the work environment and almost
everything that is around the work
environment are things that employers
could fix if they wanted to
just as we have regulated secondhand
smoke exposure a presumably public
policy could do something to intervene
and not so much to regulate the
workplace but if you think about it what
we're talking about is a form of social
pollution so 50 60 70 years ago if I
foul the water or fouled the air I did
not have to pay for the cost of that and
so if you had companies incur the costs
of laying people off and making people
feel economically insecure if you had
companies facing the costs of not
providing people health insurance not
providing people flexibility to take
care of their family obligations not
providing justice and fairness which is
another one of the workplace exposures
then those cost would become
internalized to the employer and they
would make better and more economically
rational decisions but at the moment
they just passed the cost off to the
larger society so therefore they are not
very concerned about this because at the
end of the day if you think about it if
an employee gets really sick or really
dies they drop out of the workforce and
then no longer the employers
responsibility at all so what we need to
do with respect to social pollution or
human pollution is what we have done in
the past with environmental pollution
which is to have the employers see the
cost of their actions so they can make
more intelligent and sounder decisions